this is another in our series of
internal software design reviews for the
upcoming version of Wolfram language
this one is about new visualization
functions so let's get started okay so
what is what is this data well there
wasn't saved with it it's same type of
data that you give to geo histogram so
you have a bunch of points so could I I
mean like like if I for example were to
take data from our favorite term
meteorite landings or something yeah
data that you have you know points for
so is it is it tum okay so if I get this
um come on
okay great so now I say Joe Smith
histogram of percent why is this
spinning like that
what's spinning sign
what the I don't know dynamic evaluation
why is there a dynamic evaluation even
happening there well this is the okay
but that I guess that doesn't really
matter I'm just going to time out again
but okay so you basically that's going
to work with them okay so let's say this
wonder if it's working with data set
a kernel crashed or something okay okay
now let's get that okay hit it with
normal okay so it needs to work with
data set yep
okay so that's 45,000 things should it
look okay with that
it will after today 45,000 is gonna take
I have no idea how long and this build
but let's do let's do just a Geo
position oh yeah take is fine a thousand
of them sure I remember how many percent
said can you go as many as you want
really for that percent I thought there
was a limit to that
no no just okay that's very nice
so what can I do why does this why does
this thing have this weird left hand
with opacity because often when you have
a map underneath you actually want to
see the map yes sir
so so where it's why it Steven it's
transparent oh I see so that's a way of
indicating that it's indicating the
transparency of that color on the map
correct do you really need that I mean
did you really need that in the legend I
think it's very informative
just as it is for density plot 3d so you
you see what it is you see you know
because you you might that's also a
usability thing because you might want
to highlight something so okay so let me
look at the zeroes to where it was the
page so what what what controls so if I
have I have a transfer function or
something that says what what the how do
I there's an obesity function option
similar to the color function
I never heard of an opacity function
where else do we have opacity functions
the 3d density plots density flat 3d and
most density plot 3d that we added in
what 10.2 I think but so is there an
analogous what what is the analogous 2d
histogram thing that would make so this
I see when there isn't a background then
this would just be list this would just
be smooth smooth density histogram would
be the nonzero one and why does this get
to use itself why does this get to not
say density obviously the fact that it's
geo means it's 2d so you don't really
have to say density is grandma's right
if we took the opportunity to save a
little bit of a mouthful
fair enough the other thing is that the
you know one important thing you know
for these kinds of things you often want
intensity rather than density so density
in a statistical sense you know often
think of em as normalized you integrate
to one over it
whereas intensity they kind of integrate
to count as you see that this number
event of events per area lighting angle
lighting angle here what's the lighting
angle doing so that is the thing you
know it's one of those things one of
those options are it's just Chains down
to this function so was it around
version seven or something we added
lighting angle to list density plot when
we were working on relief plots
I remember the relief plot right is
built on top of density and so then it
gets lighting angle and no I think you
want percent to
there's it percent one they say such an
actually good lighting angle doesn't it
doesn't support it I don't know what it
would possibly do look at the density
plot you can go to density plot just the
density plot yes drew regular function
density plot okay again go to this
option lighting Inc
okay meaning okay good now you go to a
different page yeah you can look at that
hmm but or you can look at density plot
under option for for an under the option
section for lighting angle and you will
see it applied to density plot okay but
so so this should work so this is just a
plain yeah does it look nice
I intend city plot it looks interesting
sometimes if you look at the options for
density you know the options section for
density plots
anyway but most of these things are by
the way maybe we should have jumped down
links from here to the documentation for
that maybe we should have a um I mean we
could have a jump down link here that
would be better you in one's a little
chimeric things are something that's
more stylized no no we have that a
little greater than greater than sign um
it's just a question of putting in the
link anchors right can you suggest that
to Brian to see whether we can
investigate doing that you know when
there is a section underneath for one of
these things it should be programmatic
to do that right and that would actually
be you serve very useful it would be
right so can you communicate that I'll
make a note and yeah because it would
just be a little greater than greater
than sign right after this and if you
click the text it would go there um okay
whatever it's way down here and this is
open by default for some weird reason
yeah yeah it's filed it doesn't even
have it okay just pick that one at the
top and save not spend more time okay
fair enough
um okay so my question is why aren't
there named opacity functions since
there's obviously one named opacity
function for image 3d are there any
relevant named opacity functions for
this case I mean at the moment you know
it's just an automatic one that is sort
of ramping up from zero and then holds
level sort of in the middle and then
ramps up to one at the end that
should be just sort of constant in this
context what's what's being used Stephen
because that means that where there's
very low density of events it get
effectively transparent yeah I accept
that I think there's a bug here right
because I mean first of all there's a
bug about why I mean I would have
thought it would Center on the Greenwich
Meridian here rather than having um but
but why did it why did only part of why
did it have this piece chopped out that
looks like a bug to me okay yeah Oh take
a look at that and there's also a bug on
the legend on that case that I need to
look into well that should be a constant
opacity in that legend right you know
should be you know gray level 0.3 or
whatever or 0.7 maybe you know light
gray all the way up and down instead of
the red yeah exactly right yep okay um
okay let me just see what other options
there are here but this looks nice I
mean it's some what are scaling
functions do for a Geo plot I think
that's probably just included via copy
paste okay I mean there's a possibility
that scaling the intensity might be
useful in some case but for the most
part I don't think so well that I know
but a scaling function for the x-axis of
something like you know square root
comma square root is that going to do
anything other than something completely
stupid no probably just something
completely stupid if it does anything I
think it didn't do anything right so I
claim that might be a bug I claim you
don't want scaling functions for these
geo things well I mean so scaling
functions has the ability to scale all
the values you know the intensity I only
like in this case you know if we do
support it it wouldn't have anything to
do with the XY projection II space I say
okay so I mean so I see so we could just
say log there right we should get the
log intensity right a little bit funky
oh okay well it's not finished yet okay
another bug um I'm doing well here this
is a bug every 30 seconds or so
um but you makes you happy makes me
unhappy I want to do badly on that um
okay let's keep going alright this looks
like a nice function though you know
much better than geo histogram frankly
we should when we knit we should really
push this one instead of geo histogram I
think I really liked what your histogram
does um it looks too much like a bees
you know beehive right I mean maybe it
looks okay for very large numbers of
points but otherwise it's it's sort of
to be high oriented okay let's look at
this list plot 3dnew alright so one
thing Steven you probably I don't know
if you notice but all these labels
they're billboards so they always face
the camera yeah okay it's like more text
labels in there yeah
that's the price if I say if I do this
with labeled well you can just protect
it just changed random colored random
word
did you notice how many are actually
gonna get labeled because yeah well so
what determine oh that's very cool
that's really cool that's very nice for
those points away right and so what it's
doing is a bit I'll take a look at that
but so what's happening is like more
yeah our label avoidance code based on
that if you know the initial viewpoint
okay yeah so so when you rotate and it's
not relabeling anything that's good I
don't think it should I think they'll be
super confusing but I would be really
good to be able to get you know how do i
specify the label density if I say I
want all of them labeled how do I say
that you give an explicit label position
explain you know so if you lay say what
do you have you know call out there so
if you do call out random real random
word comma above say
this is very obscure
you
you
it's cool the way that they do
I mean the overlap is kind of cool what
is it exactly doing it's doing some kind
of a passive we're using a yes so using
a scrim you know there's a trick that
that's been developed for mobile phone
for smart phones because it's so short
and real estate uh-huh okay and so
that's why you can see I know that word
from like 50 years ago or something for
meaning suddenly what does it mean it
means it's a surface that's transparent
so you can see what's underneath no but
it comes from like a like oh yeah yeah
it comes from sort of when you you know
when you did graphics art by by having
like a scrim what do you call that a
thing would holes in fine that's what I
thought
open weave fabric used for curtain in
the theater right okay anyway okay so
listen that this thing about how I
didn't quite understand this I mean it
what if I wanted in an automatic
position can I say automatic there or is
it then going to this I mean that's
gonna go back to the yeah I don't think
this is quite quite right because I
think we need to have a way there needs
to be an easy way of defining this
density the same is true with features
you know feature space plot it's kind of
annoying that you can't get I mean maybe
we should have a thing that says you
know I don't know not label density but
but you know what I'm saying I mean that
that is frustrating right now in feature
space plots sometimes you just want more
stuff labeled by the way if we got
features based plot 3d now yes next good
okay all right so anyway but but but how
do we specify how many you know what I'm
saying I mean we should have an option
for all these functions that just says
um labeling criterion function labeling
density function labeling I mean we
aren't really looking at the density
okay are we looking at how are we
deciding this we're deciding based on
whether things overlap
okay but I mean but first are every how
did we decide not to label any of these
guys here because
you know based on what it thinks the
image size is likely to be how big the
labels are that sort of thing it's
computing little bounding boxes around
all the labels and you know looking to
see if I put it here is it going to
collide with a point if I put it there
is it going to collide with a point or
another label well so but then then one
of the issues is what it thinks the
image size is going to be right
right so so we could tell it you know so
it is again kind of a density type thing
I mean in other words you know that
image size right a lot of things are
going to overlap right so okay so Steven
do lists point plot three of data equals
your table okay
okay just so we have that stored and now
do the same now do this point well yeah
this beauty of data with image size goes
to 100
you
you
okay and so in that case you know it's
tiny and none of the points got a
textural label they all got pushed down
into tooltips
okay whereas there okay cool okay but
the problem is on resize I see that's
pretty cool
so does that happen in feet mode where
the points are way too big but but does
that happen in feature space plot 3d as
well
mm-hm yes so in other words this is what
you're doing is at any given thing
you're you're saying label as if you
were for a certain image size right
right and you know arguably the way you
specify that I mean I didn't know this
about future space plot 3d nobody told
me this and I don't know whether it's in
the examples um I think if it's going to
if if we're really gonna do it this way
it should be in the basic examples there
should be something that shows a bigger
feature space plot 3d saying it will
render you know it will put more labels
if the thing is bigger right and so the
other thing that's slightly different
about feature space plot 3d is that by
default it's not using call-outs by
default its direct labeling yeah okay
okay fine but but but but then it goes
to single points but either way whether
it's feature space plot or feature space
plot 3d what you're saying is that it's
determining its labeling practices by
you know depending on the actual
absolute image size or the declared
image size right okay so how can we so I
didn't even know that is that a
reasonable way to do it probably doesn't
seem crazy to me
um it's just it's unintuitive that you
get a different result it's the only
case I know of are there are other cases
where generating at a certain image size
gives you a distinctly different result
than generating and then you know
resizing
there probably are I'm trying to think
what they would be by the way we should
make a comment in the image size
documentation about the fact that that
might be the case if it is indeed the
case for anything real mm-hmm
and we should say in the image size we
should actually call out image size then
in feature space plot here we should say
image size we should mention it and list
and then say that it determines this
right
okay so yeah I mean this is really cool
though I mean this is very nice some so
if I were to do instead of call out I
were to do well what happens if I try to
actually make the points be those to be
those words I'm so so they blink
function goes to center or ginger
automatic to Center well I'm gonna say
yeah okay fine but then I then what I
want to say is is that gonna overwrite
the words
I mean overwrite the points okay that
looks pretty stupid should overwrite the
point so we'll take a look at that I
mean should I be saying labeling labeled
let's try that in labeled and call out
aren't going to be significantly
different in the case right what are the
choices are there there's also legend
edge right well legend it is gonna be
completely outside of the plot I know I
know scared of a whole bunch of blue
swatches with labels and not be able to
identify anything okay cool why didn't
it change that colors in that case
because that's not what legend did does
you know if you had something else that
was changing the styles than legend it
would pick those up but
okay okay well this is nice
all right so the main thing here is just
that call out now works in 3d how
generally does it work does it work on
on lines as well and things does it work
on surfaces no no it's so so let's point
plot 3d is the initial 3d labeling
adventure okay
right and basically the reason is that
this point plot 3d is filling the role
for feature space plot 3d that list plot
fills for feature space plots okay okay
so this is our oh boy you cut the box
off really is that what you want to do I
hate that do you this front but look
we're not doing it in general I mean I
understand that the box doesn't make
okay you're right that the box doesn't
exactly make much difference in this
case well the thing is is that initially
we had you know we followed feature
space part exactly and had no box no
that's not gonna work well what about
what about some kind of light gray box
at least what about but let's try making
okay so let's do just taking its time
why is it taking so long
oh let's let's do box style arrow gray
level 0.9 it's gonna be darker oh no
because the box should already be gray
because they don't think it's not very
light gray I mean no that to me looks
better if we're gonna do this I mean I
still it has some weird you know to my
visual system this is has some some
weird thing where this I mean can you
get it to do that this thing is is out
words for me ah they see I mean I close
to true
yeah okay let's just do boxed goes to
true I think that should give us all
sick they're all honestly I think that's
better I think that doesn't have the
possibility of jumping but I think
having gray level point eight is a
reasonable you know it gives you the
reasonable three-dimensionality of it
without something which we're not doing
anywhere else so in other words set box
to true and default box style of gray
level point eight right can you take a
quick look at bubble chart 3d I'm trying
to remember what it does I think it has
the full box but grid lines on the back
I don't know it does through the door
I'm not sure I'm not keen on that
actually I mean let's take a look at
what I personally are those grid lines
really actually frankly bother me I mean
I just don't see the point yeah see
than here if we did the same thing good
things are gonna end up being darker
than me how do I get rid of the
gridlines
base grids goes to false nun maybe
what's wrong with that
looks nice to me
that do we want to get graphics appear I
think that looks a lot nicer than
listening certainly looks a lot nicer
than these non commensurate gridlines I
mean does it bother you deeply that the
thing has a I I think it is you know
less obscure to have this box you can
always get rid of mm-hmm I mean I don't
especially care for the grid lines on
the bubble chart but why don't we have
them I mean this is so much nicer
looking I'm sorry guys this is so much
nicer looking than this one okay so then
you know the question is how far does
that go are we changing plot 3d are we
changing all of the know what part three
D doesn't have grid lines no no I mean
you know everything that has a box
are we lightening the box up I don't
think it's as important okay I admit
that that's an issue here okay so let's
take a look at that
I think we could certainly lighten that
box without fear of trouble right I
think the thing that would then annoy me
a little bit is sort of having those
axes that are then darker
just feels weird should we get a
graphics opinion well I mean evil here's
what I suggest I suggest that for 11.3
we'll turn the full box on for feature
space flat 3d look this doesn't look bad
to me this looks better than us then
this crazy thing exactly I think that's
what we should do I think we should get
rid of face grids and we should turn on
the box and then we can discuss moving
the box right I think when there are no
axes lightening the box makes sense in
other words for feature space plot 3d
right but I suspect that feature space
plot 3d even without the lighter and the
you know the full box is still going to
look decent it's still going to look
decent yeah let's try it
it's fine I mean the box is a bit
distracting but it's just fine right all
right look shall we um I would prefer
the box lighter I think it's a bit
distracting here because the box is
really there's no event on the box
there's no you know mm-hmm no axe
seasons go on which is why we've cut off
to the front three edges I know I know
but weird no I mean this is already this
look honestly in my visual system I can
get this thing to look like some weird
frustum thing very easily but that is
right as you know theoretically you
should be able to get even this one to
invert no I can it's inverted it's
inverting beautifully I just got it
[Music]
hey come on you just have to think of
this is the top and then it's that's
inverted yes
except that it has this this this line
is across it which which helps to
prevent that but doesn't write prevent
it um okay
all right so look I think does that seem
like a reasonable conclusion I think so
sounds good to me I'm gonna have to run
you guys go over the vector updates
they're relatively small but good okay
and they're gonna serve up to better
vector plots in the first place there's
a few more rounds to go
but then Jo vector plots is another
thing that's coming later oh that's
exciting been great too wind right so
here's the other thing which is I mean
so so right now in this example it's
using item size in your prototype bill
depending when it's from it's possibly
been renamed to call out size so call
out size hold on a second
it's call out size a general what am i
saying so one of the issues with feature
space plot was deciding the size of the
like Ani things mm-hmm are we calling
them call-outs I mean why is it not
something like I mean this is of things
which are a variable size namely images
for example I would have thought that
this should be something like you know
labeling image size or some such other
thing because these are image resizing
so aren't they I mean if that was today
they are but it is more general than
that why
what else do I know so what will happen
is with the default setting of automatic
yeah pretty much that only applies to
images or you know similar graphic he
sorts of things and general expression
what if somebody has you know the text
of war and peace or something what is it
gonna do is it gonna make it very small
is it gonna cut it off it's gonna show
just the beginning of it what's it gonna
do the plan is for it to show the
beginning now there's a function page
for it with some examples if you want to
for what item size will call out call
out call out size
you
you
that is a very unfortunate thing call
out sizes are supposed to be used for
labels and call-outs right not the best
I mean I'm completely open to different
names okay fine but I mean let's just
understand what this does so this is
defining a bounding box
for the image objects and I see minimum
width specified by s pixels what about a
scaled version of that possibly we can
do that in the future but it'll probably
I mean it'll run into
[Music]
okay I'm not entirely convinced that we
can reliably implement it okay what
about things like text blocks here
because that's not addressed by this I
mean for example we have in in pain
right we have this mechanism for you
know resizing or what is it doing image
image size action shrink to wreath yeah
shrink to fit and resize to fit and
right asserts I think there's a certain
argument okay that the right thing to do
here would be to say something like okay
that
options that you're specifying that
apply to the labels mm-hmm in other
words so that they could be a list of
options one of them could be image size
arrow 30 means 30 pixels whatever you
know comma image size action goes to
shrink to fit or something like this and
one could you know as a courtesy one
could combine those so that one could
just say whatever this super function is
super option is so what I'm suggesting
is that there is a um I don't really
like labeling I mean this will also need
this and graphs and things like this I
suspect right and you know at the moment
this is sort of hooked up for list plot
bar charts you know it definitely could
imagine it going out you know be you
know far and wide okay so what would
happen if it was like this
all of that kind of thing can you go
back to the docks for pain real quick
you
I'm just imagining this with scrollbars
yeah well I mean um but but actually you
know using pain so that would be part of
a labeling function could be to actually
use a pain there right and that's what
this does in the case where it isn't an
image or graphic yeah so if you have so
if I do this so you're telling me that
if I were to do this thing here with
text blocks it is that right so my
default nothing would happen because
texts were just you know with you know
what's call out size goes to automatic
text a feature space plot 3d and I say
something like random word xxx
what's oh yeah
yeah okay that is pretty cool it's not
using a sensible do you know will you I
have no comment on this you know what
dimension reduces doing well it thinks
it seems to think that's pretty weird
actually
by the way could you ask the let's see
speechless place plot let's just lista
something sensible it should be using
those some would to Becky type things
I cannot tell so random I can't tell I
have no idea yeah well I mean it's one
of those things where you look at it you
start to see patterns and you don't know
whether they're really there or
constellations you know it's the Big
Dipper
and yeah I mean so like on the left hand
side there you have untie and unfasten
they think yes very close to each other
but maybe that's not going off of that
maybe it's I'm just sending mail about
this yeah sure um okay alright but but
so now if you go down you say call out
size goes to 20 say well this I don't
think call out sides good no item size
was what didn't work so so probably call
out size will and you have the version
where it's using ellipses as opposed to
what as opposed well I mean last night's
build is using the little diagonal
continuation character thing and I talk
to men about that that's horrifying
yeah yes okay there
I think the two best possibilities are
ellipses or just chop it off and no this
is nice this is nice I like this I mean
but but now you know we've got snippet
for example which is another way of
dealing with textual stuff you've got
now we've got snippet um but so the
question is really what is the general
way to deal with kind of okay so let's
just think this through for a second so
in principle I could say I see these are
plots where things represent themselves
oh this is gonna be awesome
sorry I just realized I can go have men
watch the twitch stream and oh yeah
that's good
can't even join join the meeting you
know he's not but right um but but okay
okay so all right let's some but anyway
so we're looking at the generalization
of how to wrap labels okay actually we
have a question from the talking of the
live stream we have a question any
near-term plans for pan owns pan and
zoom on 2d plots and graphs the answer
is yes
we have well we have dynamic image
already right right and I mean that's
that's the way that we would click on
that that's the way we would do this
right it's like if we're doing dynamic
Geographics I mean I personally like
dynamic Geographics better than dynamic
image but I may be biased well I
understand I know graphics I mean let's
let's just as an example here I don't
know you just close it off but we'll
make the earth
no it'll make somewhere around champagne
okay
Yeah right so now the question is and it
is a good question why are we not doing
that for why do we not have a dynamic
graphics that does that for ordinary
graphics it probably wouldn't be hard or
in particular more interestingly for
something like a graph in other words we
need a general wrapper that would allow
one to explore an arbitrary thing
rendered as graphics right which
probably will be called something like
dynamic display or some such other thing
yeah I mean the generic one would
probably be the most useful because then
I don't know that we necessarily want
dynamic graphics and dynamic grid and
don't like region I mean dynamic
Geographics is a little bit special
mm-hm but ya know I think I mean we
should we should look at that it's a
good good I mean we've talked about this
a number of times if it's easier it is
we should do it so so how would that
doing the internet or how would that
relate to the graphics 3d
I don't that's I mean you you because
you can zoom graphics 3d right I mean
you can the point about it is the reason
we haven't done this I mean we talked
about this 25 years ago
okay but what we had in mind then was
being able to make plots of things like
mathematical functions where as you you
know as you pan it could morph Ilse
function right which i think is a much
which is a little bit like dynamic
Geographics but honestly that's a that's
less interesting these days than just
having a really big plot and being able
to explore different parts of it we
should do this good idea
whoever valued customer is on our live
stream thanks good idea um are you going
to make a note of that yeah there's
notes of it already somewhere I will
make another note of it okay and I'm
going to put it in another place um this
is a rethink dynamic display or dynamic
I'm thinking dynamic display but I'm not
sure um I think dynamic display is is
some or dynamic show perhaps but I think
dynamic display is better dynamic show
would be a little bit
I believe we used to long long ago in
the ancient world do we have a somewhere
I'm I miss miss remembering my um yes we
have this but it don't think it really
exists yeah as a version six display has
been superseded so there was a function
called display but it was used for doing
things like displaying on Tektronix
oscilloscopes and things
um but that's not really relevant okay
all right good let's let's go back here
um so the issue is these are functions
where the data renders for itself so to
speak and the making sense right which
is different from all other kinds of
plots where it's um what can I say it's
it's a where the plot is merely a
representation of the data it is not
rendering for itself now the only place
where data renders for itself is in
images basically where you know so let's
let's think through what this means the
data is rendering for itself and the
issue is like an inset you know inset
which is presumably what's ultimately
being used right inset is take a thing
and render it inside another thing right
so in a sense this might be more like
inset options or something but maybe
that's too bizarre well I think it
really isn't isn't what it isn't inset
what well no I don't think it's inset
options well I mean it stirs inset
doesn't take any options but no I
understand it's I mean but it really is
the formatting of that's not it's not
labels it's it's the okay so what are
you doing here so late function is call
out but you could do whatever you want
there you could say this size doesn't
call out itself have a size option I
don't think it does or maybe it should
have
maybe it should have maybe therein lies
our problem why not have it have an
image size option or an image size
action option or yeah image size an
image size action I mean the question is
that would lead to a syntax that I think
is possibly more verbose than what you
would want because what would it so the
syntax then would be something like
labeling function goes to call out of
automatic comma automatic because you
mean oh you mean automatic for the
what's the first argument here the data
well I mean it's the data I mean in the
case of labeling function the data
doesn't the data is implied okay but
you're basically telling me that you
know really this is going to wind up
being labeling function options this is
a cheap way to inject options into the
labeling function yeah something like
that
which could be alighted down to labeling
options possibly I mean labeling
functions arrow pain doesn't work right
because that's that it's really not the
call-out is the manner of labeling the
pain is the rendering of the label
actually I think labeling function goes
to pain will work okay do labeling
function goes to panel it'll be more
obvious okay so like here for example
you're saying
that is totally bizarre more than I was
expecting
numbers index indices of the points in
the data because the labeling function
is getting multiple arguments
magnificent so I see so those are that's
its second argument is that which is
some kind of label for the panel that's
right right so if I wanted to get a slot
two or something then now I think I want
that panel of slot one yeah yeah maybe I
don't remember which way labeling
function go okay
but but what we're seeing here is very
weird why did it decide that call-outs
were the order of you know whether thing
to do
I'm a little bit surprised at that
because I would have expected that to be
centered and you know direct label with
the panel yeah well why wasn't it I mean
so look we've got we've got three
different things here we've got the I
mean we've got kind of the the okay
we've got the kind of how to apply the
label we've got what the label should
look like is that correct
what do you mean by how to apply the
label is it a call-out is it okay where
it goes because because what we've got
there is either a call-out or it is the
thing itself right which is I mean in
principle that's true for other places
as no no no I see I see that the thing
itself thing is only relevant okay
so for example in a geo plot right we
can say geo label and
see what do we do if we want to put the
the name of a city if we want to put
Chicago on a map right
what we have to do I mean that's again a
little weird because we have an entity
which has a name and also has a property
of its geo position right um so here
again what's really strange here is that
in feature space plots the thing what
other plots are there where the thing
itself stands for wet weather whether it
derived coordinates from the thing in
fact almost by definition that's not
going to happen because you need
something deriving the coordinates and
feature space is a derivation of the
coordinates
Jiri Geographics is another derivation
of the coordinates by virtue of its it's
some I think the closest analogue does
something like that is word cloud okay
except that doesn't really have
coordinates now does word cloud have any
options that are relevant to this
possibly I haven't looked at the options
of word cloud in a while a bunch of font
and text stuff
no I don't think it's going to yeah
spacings spaced out around each word I
don't think so okay so hold on so this
is so how to apply the label so in this
okay actually actually the other
question is um what the label should
look like when to bother when to include
a label because let's density thing um
right and in terms of when to include a
label there's
functionality there that we haven't you
know that we've talked about but haven't
started working on yet you know so the
case is no case you brought up earlier
was what happens if I want to force a
label on everything yes and then we have
the automatic behavior and then there's
the medium ground which is I want the
automatic behavior except these ten
things absolutely need to be labeled
I see yeah that's important is there a
way to do that right now not right now
that then one of the cases then is label
at this density
label these fiducial things that type of
stuff right okay you know and probably
whatever solution we come up will well
you know in some way allow here's the
ranking on my labels you know here's the
priority in terms of labeling them where
they may still be omitted but you know
in the case of this is colliding with
that this one wins yeah I understand
so priority order for labels yeah okay
all right so look
let's go back I mean this is more that's
a more general thing that's going to
apply in a lot of different cases the
thing we have to deal with here is
basically what determines the sizing by
the way why can't I select any of those
all I've got is and what why is it tool
tipping is that it's default activity
yes if I can only hit it well I mean
this is but that's not what yeah look I
mean if I let's go bigger and see
whether I can hit it then
while the two Danish flags I think
norwegian Oh and one is Norway and one
is fall bird oh cool
I see I see there were two countries
right right right right right yeah I've
looked at that case before okay fair
enough
well I should know that given that I
actually even visited small bird you
write you and a half ago or whatever um
okay fair enough
um what does the - flag look like now is
that one of those I don't remember it's
probably a cross but I don't know which
one you know right they um okay okay so
so okay so back to this how do we oh
wait I see we have a another comment on
a live stream from Michael Hale I wish
image collage had masking options like
word cloud I can never get the shape I
want with image collage unfortunately
this isn't quite the right team to talk
about that but what is the issue here
image collage I think he wants to do an
image collage in to make any irregular
shape perhaps or he'll possibly involve
a shape oh oh I see that wait a minute
image size display size of the image oh
it's just a normal image size yeah yeah
maybe maybe it's the question of what
shape the individual images end up I'm
not sure well clarify if you can um oh
come on you think the question is like
if you had you say different flags or
something and you wanted to stuff them
into the u.s. oh wow okay that's
interesting yeah oh okay
gosh there's a couple of outs but
woodcut I can make words in the shape of
another giant word yes very meta yes yes
yes yes no i don't know why i'm a
i-i-i-i esurance gosh doesn't have some
kind of from outer boundary to use the
fitting method to create the collage
what yeah it's an interesting question
why I mean so far as I know it's fitting
into a rectangle always but right well
I'll ask the question though we'll send
send something to shadi and ask the
question um yeah I think maybe you can
control the shape of the rectangle well
with their size but you can't you can't
control you can't use a disk or
something yeah
just um the tree boundary like my word
code
we'll see whether we can get an answer
to that um okay let's come back here how
to apply the label so the difficulty is
we could just so the self case we don't
even have a way to specify that right
it's not a call-out what is it
right it needs a name in other words
that is and it even needs a name for
other plots because what you've got
there it's it's a it's a thing where the
label takes over the point basically
right it's an overlay type thing and I
wonder whether we could actually use you
know call-out versus let's just look
overlay I think has its own thing
yeah I don't think that's
no that's not what you want um but
that's that's what we need is another
rapper right because we need a rapper
that represents be on top of the thing
right I mean it doesn't necessarily have
to be a separate rapper well what what
rapper could it be I mean it could be
part of call out or labeled you know as
you know that third position which are
then you know the position for where to
put the label is sort of special case as
settings of labeling function so you
remember when we said labeling function
goes to above you know that's really the
same as saying you know labeled just
that above yeah I understand I
understand but I mean I mean thinking
that um let me see so but don't you
agree that I mean I think they're gonna
wind up being different options that you
want for the put me on top maybe not I
mean in okay first of all in call out
there's a question of whether we should
have an image size and it seems to me we
should have an image size and call out
is this but that is a easy decision and
that affects the size of the label it
affects the image size is the image size
of the call-out right it's it's of the
thing which is the label in the call-out
right that's that's what I mean in not
including the leader and right which
suggests we also have an image size and
label itself right okay so that's one
thing and now the question of how you
doing on top label
I mean overlay might have been an okay
word there probably other words affixed
horrible um
let me see ah place no we've already
used it um not sure okay so that's a but
for right now I mean labeled with okay
but so now the question is is there a
cheap way to insert that image size
thing in something like this even though
it's equivalent to the image size option
of the call-outs yes by the way what is
this defaulting to is this are labeled
with Center is that how those things are
being put there set is Center and I
think it maybe even has a little bit of
special behavior on the yeah which is
otherwise known as the thing that we
don't have right now correct because
it's turning off the point yeah right
well so it's the thing we don't have
right now it's they display as the label
yes right now it's the ubiquitous
automatic okay all right well fine but
so we need a name for this display as
label I'm trying remember did we use
self somewhere for something Oh God
itself is is existentially you know
whatever they um yeah no I mean in some
ways it's almost identity I know but
poster
what are things that cover up yeah
sticker is an interesting idea but all
right we need a name for this we don't
have it right now we should probably
look at the rest of what we have to do
here right um you know sticker is actual
kind of interesting it's kind of
interesting I mean a label is you know a
sticker easy stickered as opposed to
labeled um let's see
you
sticker is interesting
like that I mean that's the best I've
seen I mean that's the best we've had so
far let's see um it's just your the
prediction or even has that in it and
wonderful
I have never seen that before nor have i
well teaches me to use an online
dictionary um okay
all right so sticker is a possibility
for a thing that just goes on top which
is nice and then but then do we have a
thing um
[Music]
which determines essentially the the the
options of the individual sort of items
in the feature space plot what do we
force people to use the sticker thing
which it seems rather horrible I think
we still want something like labeling
options Oh decal there's a weird one yes
no it doesn't know what decal is it
doesn't know what it is um decal is kind
of interesting I just don't know where
the decal has the sense of being
is fixed to some surface or bearing the
design which is to be transferred to the
surface yeah a decal the problem of the
decal is that sometimes they're they're
like little flags which isn't quite the
right meaning
I mean I don't think I've ever you know
I'm that sense of like a flagged decal
[Music]
but as opposed to one that's a decal
that's one of those transferee things
that you won okay so sticker or decal
decal sounds better to me but maybe I
think decal is the slightly fancier word
yes is more fun yes well okay so
something between those but but that
still doesn't address the question of
density um it doesn't address the
question of having an easy way to
specify kind of the overall size here
what
have to say I think um I mean I I have
to say I think that the most promising
will be something like item image size
which is not great but I mean where else
do we used so with item size an item
size has lots of stuff in it you know
mostly relating to grid but it's it's
also not specify width and height
yeah that's a lot of complicated stuff
what would we call the things in a
feature space plot oh great
all right I don't know the answer to
this um I don't really like item here
either because I think that's a all
right let's keep going
do you have note notes of these pieces
here or should I be stored just send me
the notebook when you're done okay
that'll be fine okay all right
yeah so this is really what we have to
deal with I mean this is look it's got
to be something image size given that we
call it labeling function we could call
it label image size
label image laser labeling size labeling
size might be better
we've got labeling function why not have
a labeling size as well all right that
does it actually sounds pretty
reasonable I mean it's two words instead
of three and that's good that's good
now where else do we have to support it
everywhere but how do we distinguish the
labeling the issue with labeling look
you know what it's gonna have to be
labeling image size because otherwise
it's going to be confusing whether it's
a font size
I mean right although that's yeah and
that's why I like labeling rather than
label as the prefix on it yeah okay
decides possible okay why don't you
inventory where else it's needed and why
don't we plan on using it are we going
to have our boy I don't know even what's
an experimental function in this
collection anymore it's the future for
this version yeah I guess these are
still considered experimental that's why
I'm considered that experimental anymore
labeling size seems quite reasonable
that's a that's a perfectly reasonable
name of option for what we have here
yes okay let's do it okay
all right and so the vector stuff is if
you open the documentation for vector
markers
who
boy a toothpick is that the shape of a
toothpick it's kind of pointy on both
sounds you know okay fair enough but
it's that fat in the middle well I guess
it extends yeah so what's your point
here it's just a new option you know it
was part of vector style under the
original design okay they throw it so
then this is the our the plot markers is
that right yes
okay and then it also allows us to
easily more easily position the vectors
relative to their point
placed following settings can be used
vector markers arrow placed of blah blah
blah okay okay seems reasonable okay on
stream markers is the analogous thing
right right except that it doesn't
support placed because streams are sort
of longer and right there's no place to
place it yes okay great
alright quick preview of very important
piece of functionality here how is how
is the Jose group coming along with them
with the actual implementation of this I
haven't talked to Jose about that for a
while I mean I I think that a lot of his
you know the I forget what the function
is being called but the the one that
does the combinations and correct
rhythmic and that sort of thing is not
in bad shape
and on our site or example if I were to
do okay go ahead yes I mean we started
with sort of the rendering side of
things and now we're into the surveying
you know some Apple you know actual
application areas and what are you doing
with graphics of an around graphics of
an around yeah graphics of a point what
about a point that hasn't around as a as
a coordinate nothing I don't think I
mean you should probably at least deal
with it transparently right now but in
the future there's a question what the
heck that should do
right I mean the analogous thing what
what happens with point of a quantity I
don't think anything happens I think
it's not valid it was first graphics is
concerned all right okay so fine so the
graphics is going to have to be you know
has to be lower level right I mean
basically graphics is low level and yeah
the visualization functions are the high
level things that understand quantities
and uncertainty and whatever else so if
I do this why does it need both of those
arguments does it need that or does it
not need that I don't know if it still
needs that's okay so it looks like it
doesn't so that's just for fun let's
just say comma 2 or I mean 1 comma 2
without the list to get a symmetric oh I
see
so 3 comma 2 okay cool I mean I I I
think the the seraphs on the on the
error bars are kind of I mean those are
in you know they're often used to
indicate X uncertainty and I don't know
exactly get what I'm saying I don't
think those I don't think the caps are
used like that at least not in cases
I've seen well at least in physics that
developed this this I'm can pull out an
example here sort the know the first
part I looked at doesn't use it in the
way that I said it should be used um but
I know people have have gotten very
elaborate with maybe that's a kind of a
an abuse of the notation so to speak to
use the X serifs you know the serif says
X uncertainty right I mean the cases I
think I've seen usually if you have X
uncertainty you know it's centered at
that point right that you end up with a
cross sort of thing yeah fair enough
well this is great so is this going to
make it into xi 3 no this is going for
12 well it's nice though
very nice um and yeah great I mean
there's a lot of different places to
support right and we'll start with yeah
sort of the obvious ones and then you
should have had this stuff a long time
ago we had packages for this I even had
this an SMP in 1981 oh wow yes so so it
goes ok well great so we've got a few
loose ends here notably the the whole
business about when to include a label
and the label density stuff
right I suspect that we might want to
say something like labeling test or
labeling criterion
I mean possibly
certainly for 11.3 no no label happens
to do perhaps
okay all right we should wrap it up okay
all right so for those who've been
watching the live stream that's the end
of this exciting episode and we'll have
more okay deal okay